ja ein Thema das Ändern verknüpft ist
mit Angela Merkel mit der ehemaligen
Kanzlerin ist 2015 wir schaffen das hat
sie damals gesagt 8 Jahre später stehen
wir vor einer ähnlichen Situation
Hendrik im Bruder sagt ganz klar wir
schaffen das nicht und damit sind wir
bei Ihnen Thema
zumindest nicht mit dieser
Innenministerin weswegen ich dafür bete
sie möge in Hessen kandidieren und da
gewählt werden
da ist die CDU ja so Links da brauchen
sie keine SPD in Hessen ja
Bruder ist es ihr Thema jetzt ja nein
mein Thema ist Nancy Caeser ich gebe zu
schon beim Namen Nancy stolperich ich
finde das muss nicht sein deswegen
schöner aber es ist so die prominenteste
filmbesitzung in diesem Kabinett schauen
sie hat jetzt zu einem
migrationsgipfel aufgerufen bei dem
flüchtlingsgipfel ich habe kurz mal
einen zweiten nachgesehen was das alles
für Gipfel gegeben hat in diesem Land
kalt gibt für mobilitätsgipfel
sportgipfel gesundheitsgipfel
Bildungsgipfel ernährungsgipfel und
jetzt ist ein biergipfel im geräder weil
das Bier so teuer wird und die
Brauereien haben sich schon ein Kanzler
Scholz Gewand im Höger Eingreifen hier
in diesem Land ist alles Chefsache und
da kommt Frau Feser mit der
fantastischen Idee dass man zum Beispiel
damit hat sie sich wirklich ernsthaft
beschäftigt die Unschuldsvermutung
aufheben sollte und Beamte die
verdächtigt werden könnten die Stadt
tragen genug zu sein müssen ihre
Unschuld beweisen die ohne
schutzvermutung ist eine der Säulen des
Rechtsstaates und die Innenministerin
über die Verfassung wacht bricht dieser
Regel genauso witzig war ich habe es mir
aufgeschrieben als sie gesagt hat der es
geht jetzt sie haben einen neuen
Tatbestand ins Gespräch eingeführt es
gäbe ein Verfassungsschutz relevante
Delegitimierung des Staates das gibt es
nicht das ist kein Tatbestand da steht
in keinem strafgesetzbuch das ist eine
reine Disziplin an dorische Erfindung um
Kritik am Start in die Nähe von
Kriminellen Verhalten zurück rücken sie
können ja auf die Straße gehen und sagen
diese Stadt ist scheiße das ist nicht
strafbar da werden so
Bundesratspräsident das kann sein nein
da müssen sie da müssen Sie schon rufen
Deutschland verrecken das ist eine
andere Qualität ja nein jetzt kein neben
ja und
ich habe mich so gründlich vorbereitet
und der redet mir alle dazwischen
ja und das ist der schönste Satz von
Frau Feser nämlich zu den
Demonstrationen im Sommer mit Corona sie
hat wirklich gesagt und das ist jetzt
Harald Schmidt das könnte Harald Schmidt
sagen da würden alle unter dem Tisch vor
Lachen liegen aber es war Nancy sie hat
gesagt man kann schon seine Meinung
kundtun ohne sich gleichzeitig an vielen
Orten zu versammeln
sie können zu Hause sitzen bleiben sie
auf Sofa hinsetzen so eine Schüssel mit
Salzstangen nebenbei und eine Flasche
Bier oder gleich ein Fässchen Bier und
dann halten sie ein Schild in die Höhe
bin dagegen oder was auch immer man kann
seine Meinung auch kund und ohne sich
gleichzeitig an vielen Orten so ankleben
ich ich schätze die Frau sehr weil sie
wirklich denn erbärmlichen Zustand der
Politik hier auf den Punkt bringt und
deswegen muss auch der Name genannt
werden und inzwischen bin ich zu der
Überzeugung gekommen Frau Faser ist ein
Fall für den Verfassungsschutz der Art
wie sie wieder Verfassung umgeht die Art
wie sie neue Tatbestände formuliert ist
eindeutig verfassungsfeindlich wir haben
also raus Herr Bruder sie sind ein
riesen Fan von Nancy fazer hallo hallo
schließen Sie sich diesen Fanclub an
aber selbstverständlich also verstehen
sie das ist wenn Ideologie und dumm Zeit
zusammenkommen dann wird es wirklich
gefährlich das ist also schon fast ein
Kriegszustand und wir erleben in vielen
Dingen solange das noch die Opposition
war da konnte man sagen da können die
doch sagen was sie wollen aber wenn ich
an den Hebeln der Macht sitze und dann
auch noch Ministerpräsident werden will
das ist einmal dumm weil ich weder
meinen Amtseid noch die Verfassung noch
irgendwelche rechts und sie meinte kann
diese zwei Sachen verbinden das ist das
tolle und es gibt übrigens eine
Aufstellung der Reisen von Frau Feser
und auffällig oft hat sie Hessen besucht
um dort Regierungsgeschäfte wahrzunehmen
so ein Zufall also meine Bitte an die
leben heißt bitte bitte heute nennt sie
halten weil auf Ruf
dieses Gespräch genau das was sie nicht
hören wollten das wird das genau auch
verknüpft mit einem Namen mit der
Innenministerin Nancy fazer aber es
wurden ja auch ganz sachlich einige
Themen benannt der zweite
flüchtlingsgipfel die Kritik am ersten
da kam nicht genug weil rum erkennen Sie
Politik an
ja zu der Flüchtlingsfrage da bin ich
schon auch ihrer Meinung Herr Bruder das
wir hier einem Problem haben Deutschland
hat sehr viel
sozialen Migrationen gehabt nicht das
Leute aus bedrängten Ländern fliehen
weil sie nur den Sozialstaat suchen aber
wir haben ja die die Wahl zwischen
verschiedenen Ländern auf der Welt mit
mehr oder weniger sozial wenn sie dann
schon mal vertrieben sind von zu Hause
dann gehen Sie natürlich in das Land
dass die großzügigsten Sozialleistungen
hat die erste Wahl dann ja ja eben und
das ist schon ein Problem man kann nicht
ein Sozialstaat grundsätzlich
haben der seine Leistungen im Prinzip
für jeden zur Verfügung stellt der da
kommt das Geld reicht hinten und vorne
nicht und es wird ja auch zu einer
Fehlentwicklung insofern als die Leute
sich dann nicht nach ihrer Produktivität
und nachdem was sie wirklich beisteuern
dann entscheiden für den
Start der Wahl sondern nachdem wo die
meisten sozialgeschenke kommen über das
Umverteilungssystem des Staates wir
brauchen ja eine Umverteilung von von
oben nach unten weil die Marktwirtschaft
das nicht von alleine hinreichend gut
leistet ja die Marktwirtschaft entlohnt
nach Knappheit und Knappheit hat wenig
mit Gerechtigkeit zu tun also das ist
ein Konsens man nimmt das Geld von oben
und gibt es unten aber wenn man dann
jetzt auch noch die Grenzen aufmacht und
jeder der reinkommt hat dann auch die
Möglichkeit
so sich ähm versorgen zu lassen wie die
anderen dann ist es ja kein
Versicherungsprinzip werden nicht der
Sozialstaat ist eine Versicherung auf
Gegenseitigkeit gegen Unglücke im Leben
und das sollte ja hat er seine wirkliche
Funktion aber kein Versicherungssystem
funktioniert wenn sie sagen die
schlechten Risiken dürfen nach Belieben
in das versicherungskollektiv Eintreten
es geht nicht und dazu kommt dass ähm
Politik verantwortliche Politik dafür
sorgen muss dass die Stimmung dem Land
nicht kippt ich erinnere mich an
Wolfgang Schäuble der vor vielen vielen
Jahren als das losging mal in einem
Gremium der evangelischen Kirche wo ja
auch also nur wir brauchen Flüchtlinge
und ist alles so wunderbar gesagt hat
für ihn sei das oberste Prinzip wie viel
Toleranz verträgt ein Volk
und wenn das auch umkippt es kann
ja und genau das
wir können irgendwann amerikanische
Verhältnisse kriegen das müssen auch
viele Leute müssen die sehen die diesen
Kurs offen mit Multikulti und so weiter
offen vertreten das funktioniert nicht
so gut ich habe in Amerika gelebt da
gibt es die Slums da gibt es enorm
Unterschiede da gibt es Spannungen
worüber das deutsche Fernsehen nicht
berichtet hat im letzten Abends ja von
Trump gab es ja die Aufstände in den
Innenstädten die Supermärkte brannten
das waren jetzt nicht die Trump Leute
die integriert haben auch etwas anders
als in Deutsch ja ja die Amerikaner
bräuchten dringend einen Sozialstaat um
das abzufedern das ist immer meine
Kritik an den Amerikanern gewesen aber
es wird immer schwieriger wenn die
ethnischen Unterschiede groß sind weil
dann die einen sagen ich bin nicht
bereit für die andere jetzt Geld auf dem
Tisch zu leben es wird dann zu
Spannungen und zu einer Ablehnung des
Sozialstaats der Sozialstaat geht auf
diese Weise vor die Hunde es gibt also
zu viel typische Diversifizierung hat in
einem Land braucht Immigration
Deutschland hat zu wenig Kinder das
wissen wir alle die Babyboomer kommen in
die Kürze in die Rente und wollen
ernährt werden von Kindern die sie nicht
haben also brauchen wir Migranten wir
müssen uns die Migranten richtig
aussuchen wir brauchen einen
Punktesystem das ist ja lange diskutiert
worden aber diese zufallsmigration von
denen die ganz unten in das System
einsteigen und dann
für die sich das dann lohnt weil sie
durch die sozialverteilung die
Umverteilung des Sozialstaates dann
profitieren das ist nicht das Richtige
selektionskriminieren
Kanzlerin 2015 geschaffen das das würden
sie heute anders funktionieren ich bin
im Gegensatz zu ihrem Bruder bereit Frau
fieser bis zur nächsten Bundestagswahl
als Innenministerin zu akzeptieren weil
ich glaube der hässliche
Ministerpräsident macht gerade einen
guten Job und hat nie wieder Wahl
verdient
und
wir haben natürlich gelernt
dass das was frau Merkel damals gemacht
hat mit mit der cdu/csu-fraktion nämlich
Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen aus Budapest
deutlich richtig war ich glaube dass der
daraus resultierende im übrigen auch mit
Hilfe der Bild ich kann mich noch ein
riesen Button erinnern Review refugees
welcome ja dem saß dann der damalige
Minister Gabriel auf der Regierungsbank
groß mit Bild unterschrieben kommt alle
zu uns dass dieser Eindruck entstanden
ist war aus meiner Sicht falsch denn wir
können bei aller Liebe und das glaube
ich kann man nicht schöner formulieren
als er damalige Bundespräsident Gauk der
gesagt hat unser Herz ist groß aber
unsere Möglichkeiten sind begrenzt und
das muss man auch ehrlich sagen weil man
braucht die Akzeptanz der Menschen für
eine Integration und da ist es völlig
unstreitig dass wir im Jahr man sagt so
rund 400.000 höre ich immer im Jahr an
Zuwanderung brauchen aber natürlich in
den Arbeitsmarkt natürlich wir brauchen
wir qualifizierte Leute und die kommen
komischerweise nicht da muss ich auch
mal fragen warum ja da muss man fragen
woran liegt das liegt natürlich an
vielen wandern gerade Montag mit
Vertretern einer der der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit gesprochen das beginnt mit
der Sprache das ist schwierig in
Deutschland weil wir auch sagen du musst
erstmal die Sprache können als
Grundvoraussetzung der Integration das
schreckt viele ab manche mit Englisch
ist es einfacher die suchen sich dann
andere Länder aus aber da müssen wir
halt besser werden und wir brauchen auch
weil wir immer wieder feststellen wir
sagen dann ist auch ganz wichtig die die
zu uns kommen müssen sich hier auch an
unsere Regeln halten insbesondere an ein
Gesetz